Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
How about some slow-motion videos!
If we would like to create a slow-motion video
and we don't own an expensive slow-mo camera,
we can try to shoot a normal video and simply
slow it down.
This sounds good on paper, however, the more
we slow it down, the more space we have between
our individual frames, and at some point,
our video will feel more like a slideshow.
To get around this problem, in a previous
video, we discussed two basic techniques to
fill in these missing frames: one was a naive
technique called frame blending that basically
computes the average of two images.
In most cases, this doesn't help all that
much because it doesn't have an understanding
of the motion that takes place in the video.
The other one was optical flow.
Now this one is much smarter as it tries to
estimate the kind of translation and rotational
motions that take place in the video and they
typically do much better.
However, the disadvantage of this is that
it usually takes forever to compute, and,
it often introduces visual artifacts.
So now, we are going to have a look at NVIDIA's
results, and the main points of interest are
always around the silhouettes of moving objects,
especially around regions where the foreground
and the background meet.
Keep an eye out for these regions throughout
this video.
For instance, here is one example I've found.
Let me know in the comments section if you
have found more.
This technique builds on U-Net, a superfast
convolutional neural network architecture
that was originally used to segment biomedical
images from limited training data.
This neural network was trained on a bit over
a 1.000 videos and computes multiple approximate
optical flows and combines them in a way that
tries to minimize artifacts.
As you see in these side by side comparisons,
it works amazingly well.
Some artifacts still remain, but are often
hard to catch.
And, this architecture blazing fast.
Not real-time yet, but creating a few tens
of these additional frames takes only a few
seconds.
The quality of the results is also evaluated
and compared to other works in the paper,
so make sure to have a look!
As the current, commercially available tools
are super slow and take forever, I cannot
wait to be able to use this technique to make
some more amazing slow motion footage for
you Fellow Scholars!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!